[Music]
hello
looks like we're live i think pretty
sure hi
uh i'm streaming goes to sashima i
started a new game i'm gonna play
through in english because my first
playthrough was in japanese
um so that's what we're doing today
let's
let's do it i'm not gonna mess around
let's just play the video game
this is the literal very opening part of
this game
um we're even in the settings so i can't
see the eyes at all
let's move out there for me
uh yeah let's go medium
we're doing the english dialogue yeah
the other options are
uh i guess i should do subtitles for you
guys actually but um
samurai cinema and then full kurosawa
mode which you can switch on and off
it's the best i use it like quite
frequently when playing this game uh
we'll do that for the stream then
yeah i can i can swap to it and show you
guys what it looks like it's just in the
settings
the horses in this game is invading our
home might be the best i've ever seen
just for the record
not looks wise control wise they are
brutal
relentless
[Music]
unstoppable is this english is that
what he sounds like we are 80 samurai
against an army fighting
to slow the invasion i like it
it sounds good i die for my people
there must be thousands of them
i like it we would face death and defend
our home
tradition courage
honor they are what make us
we are the warriors of sushima
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
go break their spirits
i'm just not talking so you guys can
experience this basically
[Music]
it sure is pretty uh
well i said at the very beginning of the
stream i'm sure people ask a lot my
first playthrough i played in japanese
for the purposes of the stream today
and for a second play through i decided
to play in english so that's why it'll
be in english if you see people ask
about that in the chat please answer
them for me so that i don't have to
uh repeatedly say the same things if you
guys don't mind that would be helpful
send your finest warrior to face me
another
[Music]
i am haru nobo descendant of the
legendary
yoshinobu atachi
it is very different in english we'll
say that much
brutal dude brittle
yep
[Music]
open
[Music]
i'm now in control
i don't think there's horsepower
no i totally can i guess i just haven't
been
[Applause]
yeah but if you get shot with an arrow
maybe that's what i'm remembering it's
scripted
uh yeah horse controls are so good in
this game
i need you with me
we've lost so many we have to keep
pushing
even if it cost us our lives as a
command lord
hmm
i think this is a really great place we
must hunt down the mongolia everyone
with me you're basically like watching
no mongol them fail
is it gonna let me use oh yeah
somebody attacked me come on i like
waiting for them to parry
but they're not very aggressive
[Music]
that you have to do
[Applause]
[Music]
good day come on i feel like that was
perfect they must not have unlocked it
yet
i did that very well
press triangle when we're kind of trying
to kill sword boys
square otherwise um
which actually probably isn't necessary
it's just the thing that i've started
doing
it's left you get uh a bunch of like
comments
i'll fight beside you to the end
[Music]
babe
this is what ac should be look this game
really
it doesn't feel that much like
assassin's creed um
like there are official parallels where
the open wall is concerned but it's
it has a unique identity i think very
much
but i do hope that assassin's creed
takes notes from this game on that same
token
[Music]
it's a bad day for everyone really
except the mongols i guess
[Music]
solid cinematics director
i am kotan cousin of kublai
grandson of king this is definitely
different in tone when
when it's in it it keeps catching me off
guard because i'm not used to it
the armor is really cool yeah uh shero
brother you always um
silvico the text is really small so i
can see multiple chats so i can't see
very well this is the very beginning of
the game you trained
for this a few minutes and you have won
battles
that let the men have called unwinnable
yes
but while you were sharpening your sword
do you know how i prepared for today
i learned i know your language
your traditions your beliefs
which villages to tame and
mr burn so i'll ask you
once again samurai do you surrender
it's a good animation
yep people be dying
um kyra colada if you want like a lot of
my impressions there's a video on my
youtube channel that's a q a that i go
over really everything
i would suggest uh checking that out for
this i'm not gonna just like review it
live i'm just gonna play through it with
you guys basically
i should have buried
sort of looks like that texture didn't
let in quite right
it doesn't look right strange
i think it's a really good opening i'm
into it
uh
so for the record everybody in case you
missed it his dad's been murdered
um he died in that buffalo
how did i get here
mongols
love a love a good squeeze through gap
in a sony game
playstation's all about those i have my
sword
oh yeah this is a thing that i haven't
spoken about there's like a ton of like
minor detective stuff in this game
um yeah it's pretty frequent
someone was sharpening their blade a
warrior
my armor
broken still cold
she's one of my favorite characters can
you run i love her i
i think so where's my sword
not here here
i'll take care of this please hide
rice
man's got to eat you know look how cool
he looks
oh do you guys need me to turn the audio
up it looks like it should be pretty
high
just so one person say that it should be
good
i'm yoona
she is really cool i really really like
her you want your sword
follow me genuinely one of my favorite
characters there are a lot of really
good characters
i must admit i think
let's move this way
there's nothing we can do for her but i
can save the others
even that i like the the comments that
uh yuna makes like
there's nothing we can do she's just
cool
was with me on the battlefield this was
really confusing for me after playing
the last of his part 2 because the
controls are
really different on the same controller
wait
lord shimra is my uncle
i have to know did he survive
i think so the mongols took him prisoner
where did they take him east along the
coast
toward castle canada they must be
holding him inside
celebrating their victory i could take
them by surprise
you'll be killed oh i'll rescue lord
shimura
then help him drive the mongols into the
sea he can contact the shogun
call for reinforcements i didn't nurse
you back to health
to watch you throw your life away why
did you save me
i couldn't leave you to die she's a good
knee joel she's a good
lord shimla can help a whole island
that is the only family i have left
yeah your dad just got killed i i feel
like i'd go rescue uncle
it makes sense to me uh so for the
record
the stealth in this particular segment
is pretty easy
um it's not like that in the whole game
it's just that this bit's like really
scripted
i like that
so yeah it's first person right now
let me tell you to stand up gin oh god
readers armed for battle living right
oh heck
move
uh yeah pop jake this does the game does
have different difficulty settings i'm
on normal
because you know affiliates what most
people will play so that's what i'm
streaming
just easy normal hard
[ __ ] clear the road if we cross
someone's bound to see us i'll take that
chance wait
oh god
okay it's amazing that this works
i'm already over here yuna what are you
doing you come on
oh okay
up here onto the roof you climb roofs
scavenge battlefields you're a thief
when i need something
i take it like my katana i traded it for
food and medicine
you what don't worry go find the buyer
get your sword back
you've got a long ride ahead take
whatever supplies you can carry yeah
supplies just kind of like sit in little
bundles in people's homes
um this game like isn't super focused on
realism which is also a thing that i
like but see like the way i pick it up
i think it's cute
you just you just kind of turn
everything into dust
throw here real avengers situation
you couldn't hold that open for me love
the man i traded yourself
so rude
stand watch i'll search the house it
will answer for this
it must be here
hello what's that that's moving on you
why is that how oh the blood just
disappeared you've had a tough day
all right
if they made a replica of this katana i
would buy it in a heartbeat
absolutely i am jin sakai
nephew to the great lord shimura uh
i don't have i am not on youtube
just ignore people if they annoy you as
murderers
i have a few but i guess your enemy is
no match for you
but you still lack control
i was practicing with your father's
weapon
the sword of clan sakai
has saved lives and ended wars
flashback
who did this to you no one
i will teach you to defend yourself i
know how to fight
to master your blade you must first
control your emotions
i can do that uncle
show me i think i got them youtube sorry
about that
all right combat time
let's see what you've been practicing
try to strike me
yes
attack i never used the stab attack
actually
i almost forgot that that was a thing i
so rarely use that
well done if you had fought like that
your attacker would not have bruised you
so easily wow
fair fight imagine he's returned to
finish what he started
and he'll use every dirty trick he knows
how will you defend yourself
strike first dirt in his eyes then break
his nose
see how big he feels with a mouth full
of blood yeah you tell him
you tell him achieved without honor
original polish we are
20 minutes he must rise above them
and never sink to their level no matter
how tempting yes uncle
now break through my defenses show me
jin sakai
is a warrior of great courage
this is how i approached most of the
combat honestly
it's a bunch of triangle and then a nice
square at all
if you held a real sword i would be dead
really i would never lie to you jin
look how pretty this is kicking up the
leaves
i will not go easy on you
a fine block thank you ah good form
thank you
i really was holding out can we take a
break
we're not finished yet find your resolve
and fight through the pain oh man
it's so weird starting a new game and
seeing how little resolve i have
that's so weird it's so tiny the help of
us so small
oh a little weak jig
yeah you can uh increase the amount of
like circles of resolve and the health
bar
obviously um it's time you learn the
stuff
wait for me to make the first move once
i strike
block my attack fine parry
good form gin thank you you're improving
appreciate that
need to catch your breath
it will take more than a child to knock
the wind out of me
now then let's see you defend against a
spear
dodge my spear then follow up with a
counter-attack
excellent counter
excellent dodge remember dodge then
counter attack
i've been here he is actually moving a
lot slower than most of the enemies in
the world move
which you know it's a tutorial
you see there is no weapon no warrior
you cannot overcome thank you for these
lessons uncle we are not finished yet
jin sakai will you honor me with a
sparring match
i wouldn't want to hurt you if you're
that confident let's make this
interesting
cocky little channel and five strikes
gets to choose dinner
i hope you like octopus
well struck uncle
very good you shall rescue
good day
before we eat
thank you question
for generations our families have lived
by a code
tell me the virtues that guide us
loyalty to our lord control over our
emotions
and you know this
honor to fight bravely and uphold the
legacy of clan sakai
those are your father's words what does
ana mean to you
i guess protecting people
it's nice playing through the game and
then going back to themselves who can't
fight for themselves
not that it doesn't have a bunch of
flashbacks anyway but you have a good
heart but first
we must show everyone that we serve our
lord with courage
integrity and self-control you say that
like it's easy
it's never easy i feel like
i struggle with it every day even the
english but we must set an example for
our people
lip sync is off remaining true to our
code
and to ourselves i think i'm hearing it
before they're saying it
that is a meaning of honor huh
that's a really good shot samurai
very good
[Music]
yeah gin
stop punk
good day good
you found your sword where can i find a
horse the stables aren't far
this way what are these
what purpose do these actually serve
do houses have those is that a thing
that exists
what's the real world function of those
things
your lipstick is off where are the
stables
i knew it was for the japanese because
you're watching the english animations
with the japanese
voices which is strange because you're
used to doing it the other way around
especially when you're playing japanese
characters in japan um but it's
fine slit their throats and kill them
without a sound
without honor it's strange that it looks
off in english too
cool it's odd
face me invader sup punks
okay yeah sure
all right that's close
oh this is a thing look he's still alive
i'm done running i can finally
i wish i could press triangle to end
suffering in real life you know me
more gods don't let anyone escape
if you don't end them they just stay
alive and keep moving or whatever i
haven't actually chased them down like a
check
i heard golden temple might be safe
go stay off the roads and guard your son
with your life
you risked your life for them they
couldn't defend themselves
tonight can't let more of our people die
they're not the only ones who need you
my brother the mongols took him
that's why you saved me tucker is my
only family
and lord shimra is mine please
i just want my brother back
i'll help you find him after i save my
uncle
i promise i'm coming with you
cool stables are just up ahead
oh yeah we get to pick a horse and stuff
[Music]
let's get to the horses can take a while
to die and it's also funny because gin
also takes a while to die
uh if you die you like bleed out kind of
slowly and they can end your suffering
too
there's some right horses a few we
didn't take into battle
lucky for them and us which horse do you
want
so because i'm doing this playthrough
for the stream i'm gonna let you guys
pick the horse i went with the black
horse for my playthrough
uh which hole should i pick we've got
this black holes we'll get to name them
afterwards
this white ish horse i guess and this
day
horse which horse oh that's a lot of
white
i think i'm seeing mostly white okay
white it is hello
yes easy there let's do it it's going to
take a while for me to remember because
i'm going to be so used to
uh all right you guys want to name it i
named my black hole snow dude
i'm going to rule out sora because it
makes me think of kingdom hearts so you
guys have to choose between nobu
and kage i'm not allowing sora
[Laughter]
all right car gators born from the
darkness
yeah which is funny that it's called
shadow when it's the white horse but i'm
into it i'm into it poetry
i would just find it so weird if i went
with sora and then every time they
mentioned the horse's name i'm like wait
a minute
just gone i can't do it
i assume they're holding your uncle
inside
what could possibly go wrong let's do it
finish the game right here this game is
an hour long time to climb you could go
in rescue on cool game don't sneak in
no we walk in the front gate kothin khan
set fire to our best swordsman
humiliated my uncle richard the warriors
of tsushima
i'm going to repay his kindness
repeating the same mistakes that got
your friends killed
that's what the mongols will think but
this time
i'll strike first wait here until they
finish them
standoffs are the best
especially when you upgrade them
um yeah i feel like camera is sometimes
i can't roll either
having upgrades um sometimes the camera
is a bit sticky in combat
that's gonna take a while to unload it's
double
circle you did it i did yeah i'm so
surprised
what's all that noise i'm not sure i've
almost fired them off at the beach
it's also weird to not have my bow and
arrow yet
yeah combat starts very simple and then
gets some
pretty layered it does happen like
within good pace i think it happens in
the
rate of time that it should
but yeah by the end you feel like a boss
for sure
hello
keep moving this way that none of them
are on oh
right
uh no dismemberment for the record i
feel like people ask about that a lot
no dismemberment um
combat's pretty it's so dope that she
actually does things
seems like the game really isn't that
long no austin it is you have to it's um
i think
most people if you play it slowly and do
your side quests it'll take like 30 to
40 hours
we'll need a quick escape i'll get the
horses ready do it
if i'm not back soon right for the
forest
good night should i leave him let's see
what happens
for whatever reason i've never looked
before
he's still going still holding out
maybe nothing happens maybe he's just
gonna be fine
like what if he just crawls forever
uh what time do i often stream i
definitely don't have any kind of
recurring stream schedule
my friend just kind of whenever i'm free
i'll feel like it
do you guys want me to watch this out or
should i let it go
should i watch the whole thing and just
walk away
oh yeah you guys can't see my health by
sorry let me
do we're gonna have to crop it a little
bit to make that work he's still going
300 yeah and then i can move it over
there you go
still going
i think he'll just kind of crawl forever
so we're just going to end it
you're welcome buddy you're welcome i
got you
[Music]
died
this is a mechanic that i think is
pretty cool um like it said the ashes
literally do make injuries before they
fire an arrow so you always know
also they're all really easy to kill
they do not armor their options
here we go get my uncle back can't wait
big day for me
send your best warrior
that's the best
you can chain those with later upgrades
and it's the coolest
everybody's dead
you're fine jin it wasn't that hard
you're fine cause i can't
i actually kind of like him
i am nephew
of lord shimmura
i have come to avenge his honor
your uncle has told me much about you
ginseng
i will show him his nephew broken
and humiliated beggie to join the mongol
[Laughter]
empire
this is your time lord sarkar
it's a great cutting
your uncle is watching
i'm stuck
submit your throat
[Music]
so for the record you can't win like
his stamina can't be broken
but i wonder how long you can make that
fight if you just play it really well
show your uncle how easily he can bring
peace to your home
save yourself
rip
um leafy yeah i started the game as soon
as the stream started so
we've been playing for 40 minutes
help me
[Music]
um
and that's how he died i think i may
have said earlier that he died in that
fight at the start he did not i just
meant that he died in bed
but he's quite dead in any case
young master it's time i'm coming here
to go
the whole
[Music]
you are now the master of clan sakai
yes you're not alone chin
your father is the wind at your back
your mother the birds in the trees
and uncle he will tell you at your
father's pyre
thank you this game is so
pretty if you ever need guidance look at
this glenn adachi
will help you
your father protected the people above
all else
a true samurai thank you gandalf
i appreciate that
i couldn't save him i was a coward
you are samurai
he died thank you stay fresh because of
me
your father fell in battle saving his
only son
his reward is a warrior's death
now you will carry on his legacy
your father's spirit resides within his
blade
he is always with you
hi andrew thanks for watching my stream
andrew works at sucka punch everybody
he's watching me i have to play good now
tomorrow or he'll probably roast him
he'll come to my fortress
um because he's really mean like that
it's my world
today say goodbye to your father
indeed dev's watching
do i feel like it's repetitive no i do
have a video about that i think it could
be if you play the game in a particular
way
um but the way i played it it don't feel
repetitive to me
if you just went story mission to story
mission like i feel like you'd have a
very different experience to what i
experienced
i highly recommend exploring the open
world which we're just about to be able
to do
it's just about to unlock father
how do i save
i really want them to make a replica of
that sword
thanks
yeah i think we're just about to open it
up so
i can explore for you guys this is the
win mechanic also the first time we see
it which i love
dear god if every video game started
doing this that would be
the best you can basically see
like just even leaves tend to just
float in the direction that you you have
to go it's
so good
what happened i found lord shimra
i could have saved him but the khan was
there
he's a big boy that khan big boy i
failed
my uncle at least you're in one piece
i swore to protect this island with my
life
and now the mongols have stolen our home
killed or some right
he forgot what it's like to fight
someone stronger than you
to feel weak
sometimes when you're staring at death
in the face
um jean i think that says to do whatever
this game definitely has supernatural
touches for sure
the khan expects to fight a war against
the samurai
he will anticipate our every move
unless we find new ways to surprise him
that's how we'll save lord shimra and
re-take her home
you'll need some help raiders the khan's
attack dogs there's too many of them
hide in the grass
nothing to see here
don't worry about it on your way
nothing to see all right thank you
i don't feel like we were that well
covered
yeah he's pretty visible but you know
it's cool
bastards scared off the horses they're
samurai mounts
trained to return to their masters
nice trick also very good they
their horses come to you it's not fun
it's not broken like it just hit a lot
of games big fan
you should split up i'll draw their
attention while you escape
i'm not leaving your side until we've
saved my brother
first i need to find more allies trained
warriors
like senseishkawa and lady masawatachi
they can help my brother can help too
once we save him you'll have the
island's best blacksmith in your debt
he'll make whatever tool you need to
save your uncle
something to scale the castle walls you
dream it
tucker can make it are they holding him
he was captured near ketchy right there
and ask around
i'll join you soon tucker won't last
long in the mongol cage
you know my early
game of the year contenders josh um my
two right now are already well of the
wisps and this
[Music]
i feel like i've liked virtually
everything that i played this year
honestly um
yeah it's been a solid year already and
it's like way busier later in me
beautiful look at you gorgeous stunning
never the same
again
[Music]
all right
this game man can i okay can we just
talk about
what we're looking at right now i have
goosebumps
this just gave me goosebumps
but just you know
[Music]
it's so pretty um
so this is the open world beginning
i think i can basically do whatever i
want now but if i remember correctly
there is a
thing to do right here oh also that's
the thing that i love i go if i
you start galloping almost just like
kick their heads up
flowers all right
you guys ready for this
haiku [ __ ] it's time
i'm gonna let you guys write it we have
to pick between
a golden temple calm waters calm mind
or a world's reflection
if i suggest in there okay we got some
for we're going with the world's
reflection okay
a world's reflection
oh hi i didn't pick that last time that
i did this so
look how goddamn pretty
okay him submerge deep in nature's shade
growth that shelters all it sees or
darkness fades in brilliant light
maybe i did pick the last one those are
the same yeah
what are we doing
okay
uh study do we stand ever unbending
or we rise together
you guys are saying darkness but i've
already chosen it now i think
rise unbending rise rise a lot of rises
in there
i think we'll go rice
a world's reflection
growth that shelters all it sees
we rise together i think the haiku sucks
i think you guys made a bad haiku um
that's my hot take
however now we get a cool headband
and the map
uh well okay we'll go here but i
actually did just want
to equip the headband
yeah look at what we got cool headband
that was it right yeah it even says a
world's reflection growth
that shelters all at seas we rise
together i maintain
i don't think the haiku wrote makes any
sense um
but dude just look at god dude pretty
bad
all right i headed in this direction
here's the thing that i also really love
if you're running
you call horse you keep running and
it'll come up beside you
eventually come a buddy
could be having trouble with the water
what what are you doing
that shouldn't have taken that long
let's try again
running call horse
and then while you're still running you
just press r2 and it just keeps
running um
but yeah i really like just so pretty
all right what's happened here
so here we have one of the number of
like
sort of town century type places
i'm not gonna be able to afford anything
right now i'm honored to work on your
blade my
for me every blade is unique
as recognizable as a person lord
sakai bring the materials i need and i
would be
honored to improve such a fine sword
it's gonna hurt your knees dude
apologies you don't have what we need to
well i figured
but uh yeah
you have my thanks we'll work on it
we'll work on it
may
this video game is art yeah i'm probably
not going to afford literally anything
here i think this is
maybe a question
my lord you seem troubled what's wrong
i saw a terrible battle near kuta
farmstead
bandits and mongols slaughtering each
other normally i'd let them tear into
each other all they want
but the violence may put others in
danger
keep away from there i'll have a look
good guy jin
um that was the dude he's trying to talk
to me
up here
person who yelled my lord oh well
we don't really need it it's fine
i can repair all kinds of armor i ain't
got any equipment
himself even broken armor fresh off the
battlefield well that does look quite
damaged
bring me something in better condition
and i would be honored to show you my
skill
um
we're going to keep going this way are
there any time quests or quests you
can't do after a certain point
um
probably i'm not positive because i
didn't pay attention to that where are
you
where are you taking me bud where we
going boss
this way how do i keep losing you where
did you go
again third ah you blend in
all right
i will follow you wherever you would
like to take me good friend
we're climbing up here then okay
that's what i think you want me to do
all right hey
you ready to see some naked butt you
guys
yeah nice
uh i'm gonna think about my uncle
because i feel like that's my current
objective
[Music]
everything he told me
i can't lose my uncle i won't
so yeah those increasing maximum health
there are a bunch of different things in
the open world to do that
yeah look at those buns
again i'm just gonna keep doing this
it's like i've already played this game
and i'm still here like look at it
though
look how pretty this is the single most
insane review that i saw of this game
was someone called it ugly and i was
like
what is wrong with you
like come on
it's stunning
ridiculous okay let's keep going
there you keep you need to sneeze
allergies okay i hope i don't die
that was not great
not a good time
let's not do that again uh
okay this is the way you want me to fall
down yikes never seen that before
just like gravity just pulled it forward
did he just
oh boy okay
horse
what do we call it kage right
ew let's do it
uh i still don't know what i'm actually
riding towards i just chose an
undiscovered location
it might be shrine
yeah okay these um sometimes not always
uh like cool climbing puzzles so
um this is probably gonna be one of
those
grab this resource first we like a good
resource
all right how do we get up here
figure it out
find a way to stop climbing i guess
excuse me where is the entry point
to climb the shrine are there any birds
nearby who can help
who are you get out of here
careful my lord this path is dangerous
stairs
i probably should have looked for the
stairs i was instead expecting it to
make me climb something just a staircase
it's possible this one isn't do this
nope nope not what i was supposed to do
not what i was supposed to do
not at all what i was meant to do okay
try that i should have listened to her
actually
she was right there and i made fun of
her well there's the bird
got it it's right there nobody worry
about it i meant to do that
uh just trying to make her feel smart
there is one one of the climbing puzzles
that took me such a long time
because i kept thinking that i was
supposed to jump something that i
absolutely was not and then the actual
path was really easy
just like that um it's probably pretty
close we could find that one again it
took me way longer than it should have
flowers another crack in the wall again
the playstation loves those they love a
crack in the wall
they love a good squeeze through crack
nice
okay okay the key
that's not gonna work we don't want any
of that ah there's another haiku
no just a thing that looks like one this
i don't think any of this is right
i don't feel like any of this is the
correct way to go
whoa i don't feel good about it i feel
like i've done goofed here
maybe i didn't okay we just have to go
down to go up
more flowers please i'm so scared of
killing him again
you deserved better than me jin okay
all right buddy
nope there we go okay
i missed some flowers there it's okay
i'm just gonna use it on my hat anyway
goddamn video game
good stuff
[Music]
why did you do that i didn't want you to
do that the uh climbing does evolve for
the record
um you get a uh
uh like a grappling hook type thing
you feel like spider-man um which is
definitely very handy in later stuff
i guess this is probably the first
shrine you're supposed to find though
and yeah if i hadn't had that weight
point there that uh that yellow bird we
found would have
brought me here anyway
um i just chose the white point charm of
a matarasu
a matarasu
i know so we can equip that
here it will
restore health beautiful
all right down we go
seriously this game's stunning
um okay
we could do this is a side quest here
let's go
hiya
yeah i feel like nighttime falls in this
game real quick
all right i'll fight you whoever you are
i'm ready
i feel like i don't blink when i'm
waiting for the standoff so i'm like
is that an option that's
sasha run up and kill him
yeah dead right from your ankles
okay are you still alive not anymore
cool i didn't need to do that but why
not you know
sometimes you just gotta do a standoff
to get you by
okay
let's keep going keep going
huh
cute is that another bird that i just
had
okay where are we going boss
how do i keep losing them i've never had
this problem before now
where did you go there
i mean that's my objective are you just
leading me here anyway
you might be quickly yeah i think it is
okay
okay
hello what has happened find a better
place to hide
hi what happened to you
there's a merchant working with the
mongols they gave him an
iron mark we tried to take it from him
but
he had too many guards this iron mark
must be worth a lot to risk your lives
for it whoever carries it is free to
travel the world
without fear of being stopped by mongols
i could find a use for that
you you're welcome to it we had to flee
but the merchant cart is still up the
road i'll look for this
iron mark stay here and tend to your
wounds
let's do it side quests
uh josh and egg roll the game comes out
tomorrow in um be careful america the
mongols
it's already out in australia and new
zealand that's why i'm allowed to stream
it
i'm sure some other countries as well
but from 5am i was actually planning to
wake up at 5am to start streaming then
i did set an alarm but then i woke up
and was like
nah i'm not doing it i went back to
sleep
hello there
that must be the merchant's card
quite dead they fought the men i spoke
with
and covenant mud
no sign of the merchant
oh the lanterns look so pretty
um okay merchant is this way you believe
okay oh am i just returning to the house
no the cod
okay got it got it got it
the iron mark isn't here
what's up punk let's do this
three ashes that's too many
oh hey i didn't see you there
no you too okay
this is too many
i don't know why you needed to yell it
when you're right in front of me is that
everyone mongols may be searching for
the midnight
there any more are you going to show up
big old jerks all right
it's one thing that i keep doing that
makes this game look way less
cinematic is pressing
uh square too much after someone's
already dead
because then it just looks like jin's a
flailing idiot
but i keep pressing it even if i'm
seeing the kill animation until like i
see them full
i should learn to not do that just to
make the combat look prettier for me
i'm too late i spent a lot of time
swiping it out
please oh heck they don't get you
i have to save the merchant with the
iron mark
he he's my brother tahrir arrow i don't
feel like it's particularly similar to
how late
to stop him from dishonouring his family
if you agree to help the mongols
he deserves to die no he's a good man
please i can't promise his safety
but i'll try to find him thank you
the mongols who killed him left tracks
i'm just trying to find luke you know
that would have been cool for stealth
okay there hit it that way
got it yep
i see the tracks yeah again tracking is
like a kind of a semi-frequent thing
that happens in this game
um you do it pretty often they turned
off here
yep still going
uh i don't want to fight a bear right
now no
no please no
i'm too it's too early in game i'm weak
lil jin
okay bear please stop did it leave
i think it did
so i don't have any of my stealth
abilities
um we're just gonna make this a bit
tough don't even have a bow and arrow
yet
but you know let's do what we can i
think i'll probably fail pretty quick
though
i don't even know if i have the listen
ability yet
oh i don't even have assassinate yet
didn't i get that before
it didn't prompt me
yes
another one you guys study gotta just
stab you right through the chest i guess
wasn't there still someone left i don't
know yeah i don't know maybe you can't
effectively stealth yet
there is still someone left okay maybe
let's see
and he's dead how about now is everybody
dead
damn it
that's what i thought we have large boys
hit me three times i guess nope he's
dead
that's usually harder another one
you can stay you can suffer there we go
you'll be free soon
you've saved my life mm-hmm thank you
mm-hmm
save your thanks your brother told me
you work for the monks any time dude
there's anything promised to protect my
family
and our sisters if i carried surprise
for them no you're brothers why did you
see sound effects there he led the men
who tried to steal your iron mark
no oh that fool
no wonder the mongols thought i betrayed
them i never had any iron mark
besides they are engraved with a bear's
name so no one else can use them
you're free to go if i hear you're
working for the mongols again
they'd sooner kill me and i cannot face
my family after this
i have nothing not my [ __ ]
what can i do now what do i live for
all right well i feel a bit bad
i got another charm
i will take all of your supplies please
thank you
um okay
these are both main quests we i mean
i'll do one soon but
let's go to this first because why not
you know it's close by
find some cool stuff
stop telling me i know does it because
it wants me to do that
hello let's roll
yeah horse riding in this game is really
good like you don't just hit trees and
die
um it's not it's not janky like at all
which i feel like is very uncommon
um even if i run towards a tree
like like intentionally towards hard
towards the horse will just kind of
shift out of the way so
yeah it's really good
folks oh well
okay hey cutie where are we going
so again if i hadn't set that as my um
track location i would have just
eventually like come across this box
please don't fight me there
i don't want to fight you
me and my fox friend how'd you get up
there so fast dude
cool i will honor the shrine thank you
and now where the fox go
where did the fox go you can pat them
that's what i was going to show you
i don't have another charm but yeah i
could unlock another one now
um all right well he left i guess so i
was going to give him a nice pat
but he bailed on that real quick
we will die if we go down that way
don't do it
bit further than i intended to jump
okay um
what do you guys want me to do i can
[Music]
like keep going uh question marks or
should i do the main quest let me jump
between the two of them like probably if
like the way that i played it right now
i probably would go
and talk to yoonan oh i can do kurosawa
mode sure yeah that's
the absolute best i can do that whenever
boom
um let's go code towards the
the main quest here unless you guys want
me to do
well it seems like a split so
okay so that's what happens most the
time when you're on horseback
is you just kind of fall off um
i hate that i don't have my bow and
arrow yet
uh the kurosawa mode does make combat
ooh didn't expect that slightly more
difficult because you can't see the
colors i think
um what are you doing what are you
looking at um
because you can't see when you need to
there's a there's a button for parrying
sorry a prompt for parrying stuff and
then a prompt for um
dodging and they look the same but a
different colors and
we haven't seen the parry one yet um and
it does make combat slightly more
difficult because of that
where is horse
but you know it's not doesn't make it so
difficult that it'll just immediately
kill you but it does for sure make it a
little bit harder
later parts of the game but generally
is freaking beautiful i love it yeah the
sound sounds older
i really like this change to the sound
dialogue sounds different too um it
often makes it rain
or uh
makes it thunder so i feel like it's
like if you find whether it gets
slightly more extreme in kurosawa what
was that
yes dude i pressed the standoff button
did i ride too far away
yeah always
oh there's a lot of you here
and a big boy the ashes are so easy ah
you got me again i feel like not having
a red just like i can still see that
obviously [ __ ] i forget that they have
like three
attacks um and usually i would be using
my arrow against him right
now but obviously i can't that's gonna
be an error
no you don't
all right big lad is it three or is it
two it's three it's totally three alana
you knew it was three
it's okay i think we got out of them all
because yeah there there's enough enemy
variety that you have to remember their
patterns
um all learn them each time you find a
new encounter um which i feel like is a
is a way that like
this combat does stay more interesting
than an assassin's creed necessarily um
there's not so much energy variety that
you won't recognize them but there's
enough that i often have to be like wait
how many attacks do you do
generally it's two or three so i'm the
one
oh well this forest is really pretty i'm
going to turn crossover off but we'll
turn it we'll turn it on again
but like you know you know
sometimes you just gotta look at things
is that a bird for me
potentially just a sound in the forest
not today pigs
hi none of you've seen me
somehow i'm right here there we go
[Music]
later in the game too some of them try
to fake you out that hasn't happened yet
but my god
that means you die of brutal death
i will take this [ __ ] all right bud
i'm bad at powering them because they
have a uh
delay on their strength
well i could bite you guys too i don't
think i will though
i'm just gonna keep moving
[Music]
horses
horse cannot swim so if it's deep water
they won't go usually there's a crossing
nearby
all right
i love some wood
i could liberate that dojo i don't want
to though
let's go we're not going to do that
is just a bunch of people talking about
lots of us too in the chat for some
reason
oh there's too many of you i don't want
to deal with any of this
well i guess i am going to then
because that seems like a bit much come
on let's do it
oh see i missed it i was too late
we just did this i was like maybe it
won't be that pope
well it isn't consistently then one
[Applause]
oh i'm very close to dying just there
i didn't think he'd recover that two one
two
oh he doesn't always do three that is
interesting i wish i had a bow and arrow
okay bye i guess where you going bud
why are you doing that
you didn't want a fight
not again
this is so frustrating not having the
stuff that i'm used to
i don't have enough resolve to heal
all right i guess the the easiest way to
deal with that is to
dodge to the side directly back
if you dodge to the left or the right
you can get a hit on him but yeah his
patents change
so there you go
i like that
i hear a lot of screaming there you are
why is the screaming necessary are you
burning people alive or is it just like
for fun
hey there's too many at once
[Music]
oh this is gonna be the captain hey big
boy
yeah you get like a thing when you kill
the leader
come on
all right i think we liberated
that oh cool okay my first upgrade
um yes i haven't been perfect pairing
this whole time it's nuts
okay yup do that we want that
how are there still people yelling oh
it's yunna
she's a little boss oh what's going on
under here
cool first person
i hope yoona gives me my bow i don't
remember who does i want my bow so bad
um okay let's just take supplies
i feel like i should go in here and see
what's actually here
hello
iron that's probably it
nope
cool
anything else oh my
nice love a good collectible
i like that it doesn't take any time to
pick stuff up
real quick
are you talking about caddies uh it's
pillow it's just a pillow
i'm not wearing caddies i promise
not that i have a problem with people
wearing caddies it's just not really my
thing
not really my style um all right
we're gonna go well this wasn't even my
objective is that what you're saying oh
no it was okay we're going to talk to
you now
do it please give me my both
you ever just you know play an rpg light
heavily stuff upgraded and then go back
to the beginning because whoo
boy
the bird
gin hi you found me i did hello
you handled that well i should have
heard him coming
let myself get distracted i've had
something in this people saw mongols
marching prisoners up
out of my eyes they had a blacksmith
with them your brother
sounds like it they were taking him to a
camp near the canada inlet
i know the place
did you find any samurai to free your
uncle not yet not yet came to you
i'm sure you'll find someone soon i'm
gonna make myself another coffee you
guys
um so i will be back in a second it
won't take me very long
um we got any questions here that we
need to answer
basically uh canada yeah why there's so
many leaves like damn uh i mean right
now
it's because they're directing you
that's the the win thing again if
there's anything that this game
uh or other games steal from this game i
would want it to be that it's so
good i i agree it is a little bit much
at times um
spider-man but it's only a bit much when
you're
not paying attention to it so if i was
moving it wouldn't be this aggressive
it's doing that because it's telling me
that i need to move also this seems like
a great time to put on kurosawa mode
it's already um
uh stormy
again wind is only this aggressive
because i'm not moving so
is it hard um no not particularly
i don't think it's hard
uh is there a system with fast travel
waypoints
yeah is it always that windy no
english or japanese i played with
japanese for my first playthrough
this is english um i think i prefer
japanese
but it is weird that the the mounds
aren't in sync but i guess they aren't
in the english either which is odd so
do i think game pass could hurt the
industry not quite related to this game
but check
the uh most recent episode of play watch
listen we do talk about that
um check uh uh
play watch listen is the the podcast i
do every week games industry podcast
with troy baker mike bertholin austin
wintery the most recent episode was
i think should games be 60 is the title
um i'd recommend you checking that
uh cool steve this is on normal
how many hours are we expecting for this
game including side stuff seems like a
540 or so
studying how we're filling up the
liverpool match and i want to talk about
it
thank you senior [ __ ] man busy man
uh yeah difficult this is normal okay
i better get myself a coffee i'll be
right back i'm just letting you guys
look at the
beautiful um kurosawa mode you know
turn my webcam off and everything there
you go look at this art
hey what's up how are you doing
how you guys doing uh
really uh you know just thought i'd jump
in here and say hi
don't worry about it look at this cool
guy love this cool
dude handsome [ __ ]
look at him my god
i don't know why anyone subscribes to me
did i spook you did i spook you hey i'm
back
uh webcam there we go we did it alrighty
i have coffee
and i really hope yoon is the one who
gives me my bow and arrow but again
this game be about 40 hours long i don't
remember
exactly who gave me what in the uh
sort of tutorial-ish missions all right
uh here's another thing about this game
that i really like
if i just hold forward and i'm following
yoona
uh i don't actually need to steer i can
but it'll just hold me in line with
wherever she's going
um that's what's a good like walk
alongside mechanic
a lot of videos screw that up i think so
any brothers or sisters
lost is my only family what will you do
when he's free
take a breath give me the supplies
please then i'll know there's hope for
our island
you feel that strongly i've watched him
win victory against impossible odds
and after your brother is free what then
honestly i haven't had time to think
about it
i know i was supposed to go up there
also this game has a really nice score
it's obviously dealt when we're playing
in um curse element
but you're riding well how are you
thank you mostly here it's just very
nice your bandages did the trick
you don't share much about how you feel
do you
i suppose you're supposed to go down
there my uncle taught me that a samurai
masters his emotions
right like garbage trucks calm down out
there
that's a hard way to live it's not
supposed to be easy
run up i'm going up
i guess so
just i mean you know just the fact that
this is the thing that i get to do in a
video game this year makes me really
happy
there's a spot up ahead that overlooks
the river should give us a good view of
the mongol camp
and we're trying to get do we just go
full circle did i just nope there it is
without putting him in danger so this is
a thing for coach
see those little little hop circles you
see in
it lets you like identify the locations
are formidable
you could scare the rocks on that side
if they're loose they might give
way alert the guards
the front wall there is still under
construction could be a way here
i don't know if you guys can hear the
garbage bag the garbage truck in the
background but it is loud
sleep inside and cut down the mongols
where they stand
if something goes wrong they'll kill the
prisoners
i've seen them do it we have to go in
quietly like thieves what's wrong with
that
yeah you're right it is like a war when
i do this and this is
moved by criminals we change that by
creating order
delivering justice in the open
we live by a code of honor
and sometimes we die by it
warriors like my father we just wanted
to give us a safer home
i want the same thing but we have to
fight back
i promised my uncle i'd never break our
code then
bend it to save my family
and what's left of yours
hmm let's get a closer look
see what we're up against we should wait
until it gets darker
you guys want me to stay in cell mode or
should i
should i jump out up to you guys
because again i can um oh the headbands
are not a requirement no um
that's just the first sort of like
headgear that you get um
yeah up to you guys if you want me to
stick with it or not
i feel like this would you chill out
there
i'm trying to play a video game on the
internet
it's really loud um all right i'll turn
it off for now
um i should have just gone the other way
i know i know i know
uh but i can basically play it how i
or show it to you guys the way that i
actually play it which is i really do
turn it on and off kind of all the time
um sorry i have all the text really
small so that i can see
more of you guys talking usually i can
only see five chats at once and when i
have both twitch and youtube in the same
stream it's really difficult
so your names are really small but um
they said that
you think the facial animations are bad
i would say that um
it's not one of the things that sucker
punch is particularly strong at
however i don't think they're bad they
just
aren't as good as you know
the last of us part two you know which
is something that they are exceptionally
good at so i actually
i think it would be unfair to say that
the facial animations in this game are
bad uh they just aren't you know up to
paul was
the best in the industry which makes it
noticeable i think but you took care of
him
someone but they're not you know
terrible
just not one of their particular strong
suits like the open world
is an absolutely a sucker punch strong
instincts
my code it's better than getting wiped
out by the mongols
we have to fight back any way we can
it honestly sounds like there's a
transformer outside that's how loud that
is
through
i still don't here any of my stealth
abilities so
you know do what we can if they see us
they'll kill the people i don't feel
like it's disappointing either it's just
not again
like that's not disappointing i'm still
very much amassed by the way their faces
look
have you played deadly premonition 2
that's disappointing for this day
[Music]
oh i can assassinate now yay
it's usually nowhere near as dramatic
when you do it ever again up to this
point
but i guess this is your introduction to
assassinations
i really like gin i really like the
characters
flashback
what do you think gin the bear's running
with a limp
your arrow wounded him this is when a
beast is most dangerous
remain alert yes uncle
keep after him gonna track a bear with
my uncle i don't think bears lived here
they don't but the fighting in yarikawa
drove some this way
what's the rebels fault we should feed
them to this bear
no he's getting this she's getting
louder and louder
so
you know there's someone you want me to
ban
let me take a look real quick oh my god
are you breaking into my apartment now
um
who did you want me to get rid of and
also why
oh we have a we have a mod in here
patrick
you guys can hear i'm gonna close the
window i'll be back in a sec
it's just really hot so i leave it open
but i feel like it's so loud
that should have helped sounds better to
me
all right time to track
a bear
that is blindingly white
i'm worried that there's going to be a
jump scare that i don't remember or
something
you gonna jump scare me a jump bear if
you will
the bear stumbled here is it dying
no but we are getting closer
it's convenient that despair walked on
this this visible pathway
stay ready gin yes uncle if it's still
alive
can i take the shot prove you can
control your emotions
then perhaps
it's so bright uh
we got him careful he could still be
alive hello
this arrow should not have killed him
something else kill him
look uncle there's a gash in his side
yeah not from an arrow
control yourself
we are not criminals like this man here
we are samurai he tried to kill you
you must answer for this crime with his
life look him in the eye
and teach him that somebody never acts
out of anger or fear
and take his life with honor
[Music]
that's a lot of blood dude you're going
to die anyway he lost his heart
taking up too much of the screen let me
move up here again
we face our enemy head-on
when we take their life we look them in
the eye
with courage and respect
that is not what happened when he just
did that assassinate and i think this is
like sort of
what makes us
don't do a lot of that the themes of
this game is like
a little bit about jin kind of
compromising his code in order to um
serve the greater good assassinating is
not
the samurai way to kill someone that's
the ghost way
different things
gin what's wrong
find your brother
i can't let them see us use all your
senses
think and move like a thief it does make
sense that you know the one that teaches
you to do the thief stuff
i am uh a big proponent of not using the
listen feature in video games
um so i haven't used it much in this
either
um i didn't use it at all and last was
part two
[Music]
but there are definitely parts in this
game more so than the last of us where
i've needed it because there are there
can be a lot of enemies that you're just
absolutely not aware of
and the patrols aren't necessarily that
predictable but yeah i try not to as
much as i can for sure
[Laughter]
he's a good joke jason you're right
you're not wrong you're not wrong
i hope you feel better rihu
rehal have i ever thought about becoming
a game dev
uh not development but it is absolutely
the next plan
oh [ __ ]
uh that's why you use listen and don't
read chat while you're in the middle of
uh
cell sequence um yeah it is uh
i've said this publicly a bunch of times
but um the next step in my career i want
to write
i've been writing fiction my whole life
i love video games i love writing
so uh i don't know when i'm going to do
that i would want to do it for the right
project
and all that stuff but that is 100
what i want to do next basically and uh
i'm a very driven person i believe i
will do it
did i pull him by his butt
that's not ideal you know is that no
not that's in here oh good okay
sometimes there are bears in cages you
gotta watch out for that
well thank you and all me yeah emma
very persistent maybe too stubborn again
i would want to do the right
the right kind of game i wouldn't want
to you know make a big career change for
for something i'm not super passionate
about because i love my job now and i
love what i do now and obviously that
would change a lot of stuff but um
i definitely do want to do that that's
that's my plan
write a bunch of fiction in my own time
that's uh i'm gonna use it here it's
just him i think that i
like can use the samples or whatever
even if i haven't published anything but
i have
i have done that my whole life how did
you see me bro you were looking in the
other direction
it's the last one anyways
that was nice looking combat i like the
way that one looked all right ouch you
come
hello cool hat bro
how'd you get in here we need to go
we'll talk when it's safe
we do need to go come on
[Music]
[Laughter]
he looks like he's dancing because he's
stuck in a gun
yeah out of the cage he's just so stoked
about being free that he's just
difficult
oh i love video games dear god
hey i get it dude you just got freed
from that cage
this is the best day of your damn life
[Music]
[Laughter]
me too me too now i get it i will dance
with you if this game had emotes
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] all right sorry bud i
didn't mean to make fun of you but you
know
[Music]
let's get to the river we'll be safe
there amazing
that's some good content are you with
the straw hat ronin
i was cut ties with them after they
started running low on rations
lord shimla has been captured and i
could use some extra swords to free him
are you looking for work no but the
other straw hats may be
last i heard they were hunting mongols
in sits a prefecture
by the coast near the kishi grasslands
okay don't let me just pick and flowers
you know how it be you know how it be
this way
we're looking for my brother a
blacksmith named um he's called straw
hat cause i guess we don't know his real
name yet but stroll hat
straw hat is a clan as he kind of
referenced he's one of the straw hats
um there are a number of them
you said they were moving to slaves
where they mentioned
azam obey and there was a blacksmith in
the last group
young man was appeared from yarikawa
maybe
you'd better be right i hope you find
your blacksmith
tucker's alive in osmo bay the town is
surrounded by walls
rushing in without a plan will only put
him in more danger
i have a friend who might be able to get
us inside find him
the sooner we rescue tucker as soon as
we save my uncle
jin tucker will forge whatever tool you
need as soon as he's free
cool but after that we're leaving the
island
you've seen what the mongols are doing
here lord shimra can stop them
stay help us fight for a home
home is wherever tucker and i go
[Music]
my friend lives in asimo prefecture on
the border with tsutsu
i'll find you there i know this wasn't
easy
going against you yeah he doesn't like
being a thief i did what i had to
but i mean thank you i guess the idea is
that there are just so many mongols that
they would just die if they continued to
be samurai
you deserve better than this
convince your people to stop resisting
and you
can walk free stop wasting my time
kill me
you think you've lost everything i
really like it
but your nephew is still alive
my men control the roads they build war
camps near your towns
they see everything and they will
find him lord sakai will fight until his
last breath
it's true it's true as will i
you love him just as you remind me the
baron in the witcher i feel like that's
sort of fair yeah
you're a father to them
will you abandon your children i won't
make them your slaves
so someone on twitch who's trying to get
me to respond to something
uh adding me on twitch doesn't make any
difference for the record um
you want me to show talk about ui
customizations options real quick
uh i have not played with them at all
myself but i can
check in the menu what they look like um
yeah adding me on twitch
because of the way the restream chat
works doesn't make me any more likely to
see it sorry
um if we go options
it would probably well we can check the
accessibility options
this isn't very much
that's a really limited amount of
accessibility options that's a bummer
uh
yeah that's a shame um okay so i guess
it would be in gameplay
where are we gonna find ui display
no ui brightness one hdr enabled got it
um hud style that
uh they sent us an email about this
i'll see what that is i don't know what
that's gonna look like actually
okay i'll probably screw it up but we'll
try
um
[Music]
interesting
yeah this is uh this is all i can really
see here
i don't know that there's much
so not a ton of options really at all
all right kage where
shall we go um
let's do this whatever this is
oh well we gotta do this first obviously
hey little fox why are you taking me
where we going today friend
i would love to see your wares
what has you done bud you what you
trying to make me commit suicide
you can't i can't do bro
okay i guess i can do that wow this
one's neat
thank you i'm gonna just out of
curiosity see if there's anything behind
the waterfall
uh it's a video game that's gonna be a
no
i wonder who's sensing you
what did you just say to yourself
it's also going to be unknown not so
sure this is a video game anymore you
know not
now that that's uh occurred
you're not following the rules of video
games so
maybe not
okay
you keep climbing
take some flowers grab a horse
i didn't mean to do that i want to swipe
400
hello
yeah i have no idea what we're heading
towards right now it's this mountain
it's probably gonna be a shrine i guess
you really want me to go up
survivor camp
oh it's going to be a camp got it okay
maybe i can afford to get some
customizations hello everyone
hi hi hi how ya'll doing
they've been seeing more dead mongols
lately
oh it's gotten rid of the hud i was like
why can't i interact with anyone this is
actually a lot nicer i don't know what's
gonna happen in combat though like it
might not tell me when i'm being like
seen if you have hides to spare
i can offer you something in return
i don't think i do have hides to spare
devastatingly oh happy moss salesman my
lord
what sucker you survived the invasion
did
so far have we met before uh
no my lord but i watched you right into
battle
please accept this gift if you wear it
they say a spirit will lead you to
whatever you're looking that sounds
lovely sounds like something you could
use yourself
not with mongols prowling the
countryside but if it leads you to any
flowers
bring them to me or other traders we can
use them to fashion dies
i'll remember that thank you
yeah i love this um
okay we can't afford to buy
something i'm going to show you guys
hats first you can bring more it's yours
none of which i can afford but i'll just
show them to you
i've got headbands it's really just
three headbands and a hat
at this point i could afford that but
that's some
naruto [ __ ] right there
this one matches my outfit
but uh
i'm cool with it sword kits
these are basically just their custom
kits um i like that one a lot
the snow demon one that's also really
nice
what should i buy talk to you guys we'll
get one of these
you can afford most of them they're all
15 so
we're gonna do sea dragon which is the
scaly one
the emperor's tears snow demon's eyes
the prowling tiger or the warrior's
shadow what would you like
currently a lot of votes for snow demon
anything but tiger is fair oh and then
someone said tiger
uh i think i'm mostly saying snow demon
or emperor's tears so okay if it's
between these two then
i've gone between emperor's t is the
snow demon which one which one which one
they're not terribly different i think
the snow demon is cooler but i do also
already have it in
my save so yeah we're getting snow demon
let's do it
okay if you can bring more it's yours
um and then the armor dies shows you
what different uh
oh i don't have that on me yet any of
this um what different
armor looks like
so this is the thing that i actually
alright
i know really do enjoy about this game
is swapping between armor when
um it's necessary so like right now i
would i would
be wearing the traveler's attire which
gives you travel includes 10 more fog of
war on the map
uh controller will vibrate within 30
meters of an artifact
so you have um there's one outfit that's
really good for when you're
uh using archery there's one that's
really good for when you're in battle
like there are a bunch so it's
you know you don't have to change them
it's not going to like kick you on your
ass
if you don't swap between them but it's
something that i feel like just makes
this like an extra immersive touch where
you're really role-playing as gin where
you're dressing them up in different
outfits
and one literally designed for traveling
i'll be like oh better put on my
traveling outfit
i just think it's really cute you look
good
you look good then
yeah we've got our
snow demon's eyes a beautiful
well okay um
[Music]
i can probably also talk to this guy
maybe
no because again i use the i'm using the
reduced hud now it's
a lot less clear there we go
now can we protect your path milo thank
you my mother believed
inari is my guardian she saw fox chasing
fireflies outside her home the day i was
born
she knew that foxes are inari's
messengers in our world
when you see one always follow where it
leads
it's funny it uh thank you
probably wanted me to go here first um
uh also while we're in this area i'll
show you guys photo mode
all the way in between stuff let's just
do it right here because it's
freaking beautiful it is just boom
uh right on the d-pad immediately photo
mode
your focal length keep
it oh keep it how about uh i feel like
that's good framing
uh roll which i'm not going to be doing
any of
those i always leave that at zero depth
of field
maybe about about there i think is nice
focus distance we're going to want to
keep that
pretty much the same to keep gin in
focus though so
yeah color grading looks like completely
different video game
but then you can also choose how much
color grading so if i do this one and
maybe that here looks nice exposure bias
yeah i think i like it pretty low too
particles is good stuff
red leaves yellow leaves
bamboo leaves
orange leaves
i feel like orange leaves are gonna work
for this but yeah you um
also have fireflies
and dragonflies butterflies
buds
this game is so freaking pretty um what
do the cherry blossoms look like
it kind of makes it look like snow i'm
gonna go with orange
and you can choose how many you want
let's go
low amount
what wind direction they're in
oh that's so that's wind speed that's
wind direction
clouds i don't feel like we want them
though we're gonna
yeah yeah that's all right uh time of
day is why it's so pretty so
there where this beautiful animated
environment can turn off or on
oh you can change gin's emotions well i
put a lot of work into this so we're not
going to do that but actually i kind of
like that
that looked better but yeah you can give
him different
emotions in here put his helmet on
uh cinema bars
the stamp to make it extra cinematic
it's a really good photo mode um and
then if you want to hide everything
that would be it and then you take your
screenshot
it's beautiful um and just so easy to
pull up
i love it okay
let us continue let's go here
yeah this is where we get our archery
finally give me a bow
i would like that a lot
all right
this uh tutorial quest will also like
show you guys a bit of the um
uh it's supposed to be like the
introduction to sort of how you can
approach outposts
you seem to want me to go up here but
i'm unclear
nope you don't i forgot about that no
we're going to the springs we'll go
to the springs you guys it's beautiful
down here oh maybe the quest is in the
springs
um
look at this
look at it oh my gosh
it's just so pretty i don't know if i
will die if i jump down there
let's give it a shot probably gonna die
he or she springs
hey someone at the end can direct me to
sensei
god it's so pretty
it uh my controller is pulsing that is
true i'm not lying
yeah i just feel like this whole area is
gorgeous and i had people ask me after i
made um that q a video that i made about
this game
about you know if there are any areas
where there are just people like
regularly living like towns or whatever
and yeah they're absolutely would that
be the
blade of clan sucker yes
was this bamboo yeah i love these that
is one worth knowing
i've heard tales of its sharp edge and
beauty
but i never dreamed i'd see it in person
there's been some time since i trained
over by boosted
i would be honored to see your blade in
action
okay let's do it other way got it
okay
there are a bunch of these like
scattered around the world l1 xx l1
triangle
l1 xx l1 triangle triangle l1
oh i forgot it l1 xx l1 triangle
triangle l1 okay
oh okay okay it's fine
so close
that one i hit i hit triangle three
times
yeah some of those are really easy
sometimes the combo is super easy
sometimes that's tough
hey have you got more resolve love to
see that
um the suck i steal is that
but yeah you have to you have to hit it
pretty quick wielded by an even
finer swordsman but training with bamboo
will only make you stronger
i'll need strength for what lies ahead
there are bamboo stands throughout the
island
they will help sharpen your skills on
the job yeah
farewell my lord
that's a lot of wind um okay
i'm gonna i'm gonna turn the waypoint
off because i'm right here anyway right
um so that the wind stops
i'm gonna just walk down here correctly
because it's so freaking pretty
all right peasant you don't know me
that's another happy moss salesman i
should collect these flowers shouldn't i
i love it i love it the most ah
okay
i shake my head at this game so much i'm
like how are you going to be this pretty
dude how are you going to
are you serious
i believe this is our question hello
a summit it's quite a hairline
the water looks like that because of the
springs for the record it's the
chemicals in the springs generally the
water doesn't look that light blue um
it's definitely supposed to look the way
that it does
did the sensei not fight komoda no
he came to town for surprise the day
before the invasion
hardly spoke a word but he's always been
a private man
my lord are the stories of sensei
ishikawa true
what stories they say he sank a pirate
ship with a single arrow
not the ship but he shot a pirate
captain from the shore
uh the whole fleet i'd hate to cross an
archer like this is an example of
because i'm following someone i don't
have to actually control the direction
i'm walking in it just does it
yeah it's he's just like circling for me
right now i don't i'm not controlling
any of this really
sorry mate got ahead of you there
oh yeah i remember the sensei's dojo is
up there on the cliff
thank you i'll take it from here
one more question my lord may i ask why
the sensei left his post as archery
master declan nagao
no one knows strange mysteries
giving up service to a great lord for
this
nobody asked your opinion in keeper oh
if i had my bow and arrow you could
shoot the bees down and it will
damage enemies but i don't have them yet
soon
okay
okay
i think i saw an investigation yeah
better look around
let's do it the lip sync is weird in
japanese
yeah who developed this this is suck a
punch
who uh you might know for making
infamous also made slight gooper
someone was wounded remove the arrow
okay so i'm supposed to still be in the
dojo
i missed something
oh that'll probably be it yeah i did
miss
a lot of blood the victim or the
attacker maybe the sensei is in his
house
a humble home for a samurai
hey cool guys don't move sensei ishko
lord sakai's boy
you survived komoda we could have used
your bone
i was on my way attack me
look at him kingdom to return
samurai is never caught by surprise
i'm sorry about lord shimura he was a
good man
he's alive taken captive by the mongols
then there's hope that's why i've come
help me save him i can't
my student is missing a skilled archer
i will help you look then you can both
help me free
lord shimra
try and keep up sakai let's do it
uh no john this is not a sequel
this is uh it's such a unique game for
the studio to make but um
no definitely not a sequel
i just got a work message sorry guys
give me a second no one knows
are there any others who can fight back
besides us
i don't know yet you'd better find out
quickly
we can't free your uncle by ourselves
cool jacob sent me a message i thought
it was work related it was actually just
him telling me that he thought the no
man's sky update looks cool
[Laughter]
all right
i can help track your student i need no
help checking somewhere
a woman yeah jin from what clan no clan
a peasant but she can out shoot any
samurai i know
even use okay i ain't even got a bow
dude
you are not the time i saw you was ten
years ago
you came to study with me you remember i
remember most of the students i reject
instead you took this tomoe as your
student
you showed promise is a prodigy
g'day lads mongols
all right i expected him to come to me
but he didn't
uh
[Music]
i love that they actually do things i
always think i'm gonna have to take care
of everyone but i don't even danuki can
catch a tiger when it's sleeping
wow that's you're quite dead
all right
why do they not have footprints the
moist trail picks up here were they not
also on this road why is she the only
one who has footprints
the mongoose took for nakayama the
patrol likely came from there that's
close to the hot springs
the town will be the next to fall
something happened here ambush uh yeah
there isn't a lock on
i sort of wish there was um
she's just really happy oh
tomorrow um yeah there is no walk on it
i do sort of wish that there were
but rice and millet left uneaten
the attack was sudden
um okay a japanese quiver a gift
to my greatest student
is there something else for me to find
you uh-huh because the
again that hud is off now not much no
one died i think maybe maybe
that those things wouldn't have symbols
anyway i'm not sure
i like this mode though don't worry
would never leave the quiver behind
unless she was pursued or captured
can i take it what end can i have the
quiver interrogation
torture worse
they may be doing the same to lord
shimra
fear is a weapon sakai do not let the
mongols use it against you
[Music]
your student where would they take all
right
the fort is nearby
now john smith has sent me a work
message but it's just
this cat
why why are people using work channels
to send me this
this information
for everyone who doesn't know i work for
youtube channel called fun house well
it's more of a media company really but
youtube.comhouse and i guess uh
colleagues uh currently sending me
completely unrelated things
i think john's watching that's why that
happened i feel like i
just felt like animals wrong answer i
saw it with my own eyes could have just
texted me john relies not on
eyes but on body mind and spirit
stop here we need to talk
what's wrong sensei this bow
was a gift to me from the naga many
years ago
it's a beautiful weapon of course it is
and there's nothing more painful to me
than a perfect bow
ineptly used and it's a good thing
you're giving it to me
who said anything about giving prove you
can shoot straight
i'll let you borrow i love how sassy he
is try it out before we go
i will say while it's really jarring for
me again having played more of this game
and then jumping back to this
part to not have any of these items like
it's very weird because i feel like i
use the ball a lot in combat
um i do like that they
show you receiving every weapon that you
have i feel like it's it's a really nice
touch to have it
um be made significant
even for that lamp closest to us
another one further down the road on the
left on the left
the further the target yeah the more
your arrow drops
probably too high yeah focus all right
i'm getting used to the grip okay still
lower
about there how does it feel
like it was made for me it wasn't
so take good care of it be so sassy
let's go
uh i only have one ranged weapon right
now so this doesn't do anything but yeah
generally i'll have like other stuff
mapped to d so you hold
l2 and then you can jump between these
and then r2 is actually how you change
your um
combat stances it is actually crazy to
me that
this is like two and a half hours in
hope that commodore it is a good ball
a victory is one by one around a little
bit but you haven't seen the mongols
fire weapons
it's two hours in and i still don't have
even like half of my not even not even a
touch of my combat options
just um i guess this took longer than i
remember
i hope your student is inside
all right let's take down a fort shall
we get a better look at the defenses
from up there
this spot is perfect
i'll find a way in open the gate then we
hit them you always charge
into battle with your hakama half tied
you have a better idea
patience it's okay the mongols will send
men to find their missing patrol
when they open the gates we strike the
longer we delay
the longer remains in danger calm down
jen
she can take care of herself survey the
battlefield
what can we use to our advantage bees
hornet nests
one shot let's get them up the mongols
will face the sting of insects and
arrows
explosions those barrels could do some
damage
we'll find out
and now and those hanging lights will
kick up sparks
and start fires
they have many outros they're skill we
are better
hope so when the gates open distract the
enemy
and rain arrows on their heads then we
storm the fault
and free tomoy good now we wait let's do
it
they're opening the kits wait for my
signal
you guys are really just sitting right
in those hornets huh
really just all up in that
i'm still waiting for your signal dude
i'm still get ready
now send them to their ancestors
i'll probably do this one too i think
not terribly effective oh let's go with
barrels
cool
oh i missed
okay i guess we're not going down yet
all right
how fast you draw and fire
by a pretty significant amount
you can also get an upgrade that i need
to remember that i don't have it uh you
can block arrows with your with your
sword which is uh it's cool it's like
some star wars
uh yeah i don't have that yet
they're more inside i just want to get
those supplies
around
g'day lads i could stealth through here
maybe i don't know if they all
no no it won't work
all right hello hey who would i come
from
[Music]
come on mate
[Music]
i guess i don't know how much help they
have now because i'm playing with the
expert hud
it looks great i like this a lot um i
think when i first downloaded the game
it wasn't available yet you needed to
get an update for it if i remember
correctly
obviously in the settings now
oh there you are oh there's two of you
what's up
oh there's another one on the other roof
that's why i'm gonna run out of arrows
though
oh those are spikes um
six is all right actually okay
another one up here
too high
not super worried about you i'm being
honest
i'm all worried about big boy oh he took
him down okay
all right that was rude
just that one on the roof left hey
he didn't yell yeah that's everybody
all right yeah the
constant transition between um katana
combat and both combat
is something that i really enjoy wait
this pendant belongs to her
search the fort
searching the fort
these arrows are japanese to moyes
arrows
you are sure i taught her to make the
knock with dear horn
and that curve of the evil feathers so
the mongols took her weapons
the shots are tightly clustered she did
it no [ __ ] shoots japanese arrows with
such skills
then they allowed her to use a ball
oh thank you jed i appreciate that my
family are very safe and well
uh being that they're in queensland
australia
where there are like zero cases
currently or something
your name is mentioned she was teaching
them my way of the bow
hunt and fall supplies
the first time that i did this i
definitely i think i stealthed a bit
more
someone's cause i remember seeing
someone in this room when i got to this
point
the mongols feed her why
do you hear that a survivor peasants are
so demanding
oh where did you go
ishikawa
bro there you are it's so
good it's dramatic
she died silently an archer
mungo's cage too with us
but they set him free gave her armor and
a ball
she killed my wife and the others
the bodies we found she proved her skill
to the enemy
and they recruited her
please it
it hurts
sorry bud
i've seen enough very dramatic death
i should have killed her sensei the way
he won her freedom
she joined the mongols why would she do
that
what happened i pushed her too hard
mr howe what are you hiding
sensei
i demand an answer she attacked me
not bandits
why she has no idea what it means to be
samurai
you drove her to the mongols
do not judge me do not lie to me
i can't let tomoy teach my way of the
world to the enemy and we will stop her
this is my fight i don't need your
weapon no you need me
victory is won by warriors not
weapons sometimes also by ghosts
raised you well
we'll hunt them away together but we do
it my way
and when the time comes you will help
rescue my uncle you have my words okay
i will prepare to hunt them away when
you are ready
meet me at my dojo we can't rescue my
uncle alone i need more people to join
our fight
fine lady masako adachi if she's still
alive
she's one of the finest warriors on the
island
thanks for the hot tip
it's cute
okay yeah i like that they call missions
tails
it's cute everything's just cute really
my legend gross
i love that for me the mongols are
everywhere
in a fight they will surround me like
wolves
i need to find new methods to keep them
at bay
all right so first stance oh ghost
weapons
oh kunai rules um
yeah i love that well-balanced blade i
can throw
to catch a full by surprise you can you
can finish level it up
to the extent that you can kill someone
just by using it it's it's really good
yeah let's do that uh there are some
other abilities that i feel like i
really want right now
um
i've already got this
like i want roll i think
because it's weird to not have i'm gonna
buy roll
um
i'm trying to like figure out what ones
i keep missing the most i don't i
haven't
don't need any of those um
that's really handy
you can't even get that yet
i i do want that
that's also really good
so is that i'm gonna do that ah
that was tough it was tough
all right kage all right all right pipe
down
okay three tails updated
i could do that or we could continue on
the
main quest i kind of want to go hang out
with yoona again
um oh let's see what's nearby first
shall we
nothing really
uh let's continue on with the sensei
then
i think
it's nearby let's do it
his name is not roach he is much better
than
um can i change the difficulty mid game
i imagine so
let me check options gameplay
yup sure can
let's go kurosawa mode uh cause it looks
good right now i like doing it when it's
rainy
fame okay
uh yeah the horse is upgradeable
basically yeah
[ __ ] sorry jim
ooh bud you can make me climb again
aren't you
bud where did you go how do i keep
losing the buds
where are you where are you because it's
not bright yellow it doesn't stand out
there you are there you are there you
are
what are you taking me i'm ready to roll
where you i will follow
anywhere that you tell me
too
[Music]
i think it is come on bud
why did you do that was he trying to
lead me here i don't i don't buy it
there's gotta be
a bath nearby it has to be that's what
he was trying to lead me to
it's just that that functionality is way
more difficult in curacao mode
it's gotta be surely
oh well it's fine
what up big man
hey
sensei any word on tomoy
yes but i'm not sure you are ready for
her
you make her sound like a demon that's
not far off the mark
is fearless she is not samurai
but she is a born killer i know the type
of twitch is clear that's strange
youtube could be capping me may do that
sometimes
oh uh now for the record the kurosawa
mode is um
is supposed to be grainy uh
in case you guys didn't know that um
yeah it is literally supposed to look
grainy like an old film
um it makes the game look
worse because it looks like a movie so
it's very much intentional
if tomorrow is truly fearless she'd make
a useful ally
the starving leopard is fearless too
leopards can't master your way of the
ball
let it go sakai you'll never join us
why did she turn against you i took a
risk sharing all i knew with her
when she betrayed my trust i punished
her it must have been harsh
you saw what she did to the prisoners at
fort nakayama
that was no mistake that was a choice
and not the first time she's made it you
don't know it was her fault
you don't i do i love him he's so sassy
i think this is the quest where i get my
archery outfit
if i remember correctly
it's probably going to be pretty up here
so i'm going to change it back
stunning ass video game
you taking me climbing
you have to climb to get there okay sure
you can make it sincere
what are you waiting for today i'm not
i'm literally right here
i did the climb you need a hand says
where did he go
oh he just paused me and i didn't see it
what's this what's this what's this
you said the only way up was to climb no
i said you had to cry it's good exercise
i love them arrows [ __ ] and japanese
if they were here they're long gone we
might pick up their chair by the
practice target
there is no target
near that watchtower not there
i'm literally running dude get on my
back
how many mongols is tomorrow training
oh dog sorry
and that's the camera
ah it's not fair when there's two of you
i could but i don't feel like i need to
right now okay it's gonna make me okay
it is they are really cool ah stop
are you dead are you stumbling what's
happening
okay got all that
good work thank you appreciate it
resting your bow arm sensei
observing your response to an ambush
you knew those mongols were still here
yes
you didn't think you mentioned it you
can't handle a few mongols
what good will you be against this is
war not a test
and how many wars have you fought
i'll test you as i see fit
i can see why tomorrow attacked you
uh no zeef um
this game has not made my playstation
fan loud really at all actually
where did she go um i am playing on a
playstation pro
a lot of tracks a dozen men maybe more
follow the trail have a good clip
all right
if we catch you do not wait for me
attack and keep moving
or you'll die do you plan to use your
bow this time
if we find her and if not can you take a
dozen enemy soldiers without me
probably if i must good answer
i think i think it's curacao mode vibes
i'm sorry you guys uh to everyone who
wants color i just think it suits what's
happening right now so i'm sticking to
it
i feel like it works you know
it's rainy and it's just a really green
area rather than a colorful area
kind of on a little detective
some detective works so yeah
yo r.i.p you got messed up
hey boys where are we dropping
look at them and they're practicing what
tomorrow taught them
murdering the innocent
how do you know if they're innocent how
did you know that
how we want to do this
that might have been a bad idea
i feel like i want the captain
but i'm going to take this dude out
first oh [ __ ]
that is uh definitely significantly
tougher without
they're um like a lot meters oh hey bud
you're right here
hello captain try me come on
come on
oh i think he did hit me damn it i was
like yeah parry
no he got me
yay new stance
this one is helpful against people who
wear shields or have shields probably
not wear
forgetting that i don't have the thing
where i can block arrows yet
oh [ __ ] yeah that's going to be a
problem in this mode probably
didn't that really miss um yeah you get
this like big notification when
someone's trying to kill
a captive yeah it's not going to tell me
i'm going to make the game real hard
because if they're already and they kill
them i'm screwed
oh no no no no no oh no no no
oh no oh panicking where are you and are
you killing villages
no maybe not you're just hanging out
right here okay that's fine
uh let's swap
you are quite dead
cool
i probably have to go talk to the
villager
i could use that hornet's nest too
hey friends please release me yeah yeah
i mean you could have left by yourself i
don't know that you needed to be that
bad with these mongols i couldn't
believe it
she was giving them orders what did she
say
something about the sensei and the hot
springs that's
all i heard my lord forgive me
where are you bud oh
hey
hello
there we go
which i really like mentioned hiroshi
springs she's just getting
it's a started the way you fight
it's not your uncle's way and it's not
mine
we've never faced an enemy like this i
do what i must to defeat them
a samurai is a guardian not a killer or
darts around like a thief
you didn't see komodo i've seen enough
i know it was brutal but i won't train
another monster
i know i won't let that happen
if donald is going after yoshi springs
i need to prepare so do you i'll see you
at my dojo sakai
cool oh didn't mean to do that
nope okay
alrighty do i have any upgrades right
now
well i knew that i had that there's
nothing i can do yet i don't think
oh it is upgradable
okay i should maybe um go find a camp
uh it's the closest let's go
is horse gonna be able to do this
[Laughter]
apparently not no okay
let's go to the camp
and upgrade my bug
hey fam because it doesn't have
i'll show you guys what it looks like
when you don't have that expert
uh hud style on
see it just it has little logos for
everyone that you can
interact with which it got rid of i
suppose for uh
for the um my lord it does it is more
immersive for sure how can i help you
you're a trapper i don't know that
anyone here actually can help me i don't
think you do upgrades you just do
oh i'm sorry that was an accident i did
not mean to hit that
um you just see your positions here
yeah vanity gear i will take a look it's
yours
lord come on buddy come on it's pretty
oh i don't even have that yet you have
my thanks uh we need to go to a golden
temple then
not enough people of use here
uh which is gonna be is it this one
no but i could do that actually the boa
is
literally right there let's go here
first i think
and then go upgrade
i don't know what this undiscovered
location is going to be uh where are you
all right let's go
you've been streaming three hours
huh yeah yeah i will have to finish at
three because i have a meeting or before
three so
um but i could stream more later if you
guys would want oh hello
hello hello you're my best friend where
where are you taking me
did you want me to go inside here no oh
that's my track location anyway okay
time to see more of jin's butt um
where is the nearby poster that can't be
right that's what uh
i well see it so
all right
let's get naked
gotta get that ass out
yeah i might come back and stream after
after i do a bunch of work stuff
that would be chill i have to have a
meeting
and then i'm streaming soviet jump with
uh
aaron from gamegrumps for um inside
gaming
okay reflect on creature comforts
sure
the only thing i'm missing is a strong
drink
a bowl of miso oh that does sound good
some sleep
not too a woman oh
nice gin nice nice nice nice nice nice
naked man
uh i'm gonna go to the bathroom real
quick you guys i will be right back
just you know let you hang out with jin
in this nice pool
there we go beautiful video game
uh
i'm back
uh do i know if i said anything about
the next time i'm gonna play daily
premonition too
look i'm not a streamer um
so it's not something i do on any kind
of schedule i just kind of do it when i
like can
if that makes sense so i will probably
stream deadly premonition too again
i don't know when uh it'll just kind of
show up
um because i don't like committing to it
because you know i can work a long day
and then have to
just not want to be on camera again etc
uh so i yeah i'm sorry i have no idea
okay we're gonna go we'll do this quest
and then upgrade bob
all right cool nice jump
is someone in there huh
oh hey all right what are you doing
in here just hanging out
cool okay hey what's up thing about life
the mongols have taken the bridge
leading into hiyoshi springs
many people travel that bridge they'll
be vulnerable to attack
i'll go there see what i can do thank
you my lord
mel cotton rejects it how's the game
looking so far i'm trying to decide if i
want to grab it now or not
i would suggest that you just look at
this stream i feel like it's easier for
you to uh
you know decide yourself based on
watching gameplay then for me to
try to tell you what you might like or
not
i thought i heard animals
all right see what happens that's a bear
yeah you get those mongols bear
they stealing my homeland
oh my god
oh no i think they got the bear
that dude for sure died though
i am still in my shield stance good
day i will take all of your [ __ ]
did i get the bear's stuff oh he just
says kenai which i already have
okay
game two pretty game two
it pretty be illegal
all right
yeah up up
he's taking me where i'm going again or
is this the same bird as last time that
i had beef with like are you always
trying to take me to this dojo or is
there genuinely something near this dojo
that's helpful
i think there is and i just haven't
found it yet i'm gonna follow the bird
okay where do you want me to go bro
where are we dropping lad
down
okay you better not be [ __ ] with me
bird
you son of a [ __ ]
where did you go
i wonder if those birds are circling
something specific
uh i feel like i lost you again bud
you're the worst you're the worst i
don't know what it wants
there's got to be something in here that
i'm not seeing
right
it's fine it's fine
[ __ ] hello sensei
fireworks do make an appearance in this
game right
travelers have been shot dead on the
roads in and out of hiyoshi springs
people are afraid to leave or deliver
supplies
you think that's our doing a few archers
strategic points can isolate a whole
town
a tactic of yours when you were clan
nagal's archery master
tomoe was a good student too good
we're fighting your own reflection
we will turn that to our advantage
come
how do you propose we find these archers
we think like tomoe
is that sudden weather shift
we want to control movement in and out
of yoshi's speech oh yeah
where do we put archers
here i suppose a handful of men could
shut down the road to the coast oh thank
you jedi
have a good day
that path behind then no poor cover
no clear lines of sight you want to
cover the largest territory with the
fewest archers
i mean yeah that seems right i would
want someone looking over the bridge
into town
so would i
it would be smart to control the main
entrance to town
people already avoid the main road
archers there
would be wasted
there's another one you want me to find
where it at
further away okay the road south runs
along a high ridge
perfect place to rain down arrows tomoy
would agree
there's hope for you let's go hunting
gotta reach the coastal road huh
uh
yeah maybe
going back down i think maybe i'm unsure
he seems to want us to go down and then
that way
i think
all right
so pretty
oh hey dude
i studied poetry with your uncle
the mongols have taken lord shimla
captive
he will endure he is strong and
resilient
skilled in the arts of combat and poetry
do you practice haiku i do yeah there's
no time during
oh i mean no is the reason to make time
haiku allows one to concentrate
eliminate chaos to find peace precisely
my favorite place to ride lies atop the
cliff it is one of many such places
if you look you will find inspiration
all across
sushima i hope i can find quiet places
like this one
untouched by war
[Music]
look for the birds they will show you
the way piano
um okay i do like that it lets you start
all the quests or interact with other
people even when you are in a quest
um there are limits to that that it will
occasionally be like if you engage in
this tale it will end your current tale
ah yes but we can do a high crew right
now even though we're in the middle of
the quest
i swear i have suffered in my eye god i
keep sneezing you've got allergies it's
just
it's just a mess out here you guys want
to write this haiku for me again
we're choosing between
clear skies and clear mind
feel the earth below or whispers through
trees
what say you
sky earth whispers i feel like there's a
bunch of uh
whispers i think i'm seeing most
whispers mostly
which was whispers three trees let's go
swing freely in the wind a cool bed
beneath stars
protect it from the harsh sun make it
make sense this time damn it
[Music]
stars
hmm this is a pretty big mix
bed star sun
okay i'm guessing stars i think which is
this one
ah a sturdy defense
growing ever strong or where's the last
one
aha beckoned by the warmth
i think this is going to be a
nonsensical poem again but i guess
that's what happens when you write poems
by committee
warmth warmth is getting the most for
sure
which is going to be the top one all
right what garbage did we write this
time
whispers through the trees
a cool bed beneath the stars
beckoned by the warmth doesn't make
sense
the old man was right my spirit feels at
peace
strongly as she can pose the beckoned by
the warmth one is what makes the least
sense new
you headband what up
yeah all right
sorry about that i had to um do poetry
you understand do you understand
oh that's not gonna be a good idea for
us is there a bridge
let's go over here
what else did you teach tomorrow yeah i
held back nothing
including why you left clan we're
getting close eyes open
oh this is pretty
show me your stuff i'm not gonna go stop
oh he dead
oh
you too squishy dude don't even bother
with me
i wasn't here keep moving i have to
search corpses first please give me a
second i'll keep moving once i've
searched these corpses you understand
all right let's go this way
nope this way
all those innocent dead tomorrow has
thrown everything away
betrayed her people she is a traitor
because the mongols are for power
wealth status things denied her by birth
tomorrow i knew she was born to a lower
station than she deserved
now you're being too kind
kindness can be useful even to a warrior
who told you that
sun tzu my uncle and he didn't tell me
he showed me mercy creates a debt your
uncle showed mercy to people who pose no
danger to him
a safe bet i just really like the
characters in this game man
like the fact that even this dude is as
interesting as he is is just
i don't know cool
okay ambush where from
where did you just shoot that arrow into
sure it's these guys that you wanted me
to attack but not much of an ambush
all right all right okay
[Music]
oh you got him nice one sensei
okay
damn it he's too good
one more snakeness to find come
how did tomoe become your student
she showed up with my dojo with her
father's makeshift hunting blow
and refuse to leave you didn't turn her
away
i tried but she slept nope i thought it
was a snake
it's about a disregard i've never seen
talent like hers
she must have had training okay
would have been useless in a real fight
but she had no fear of missing a shot
a warrior's spirit no
killers i didn't see until
got a real kylo ren on our hands
i'm not entirely sure if this is where
you want me to go but it feels like it
is so
let me keep doing it
i don't know what happened to the sensei
what mongols
all right fight me i'll kill someone
i'll show you
ah
run up to the arches yeah some of them
shoot like three times in a row too it
can be a real
pain in the butt
got away with that one
that was a cool trip uh is that
everybody
ah chuckles think it is
where the hell is my sensei
i feel like the music's telling me that
someone left but i can't see them
a bit late mate bit late
that's the captain
i didn't see a king coming oh
all right all right all right
speak sensei all of hiyoshi springs will
beg for mercy
like the victims of hirono in other
silence
he's not [ __ ] around
didn't he die fighting bandits it was
decades ago he was reputed to be a great
archer
did he study with you no tomoye
is spreading lies there's a seed of
truth she wants
us to doubt each other why so
defensively we're all that stands
between
he or she springs and a bloodbath
and we stand together
we'll plan the town's defense at my dojo
meet me there and be ready to fight
okay i would die for these springs
that's my okay
cool let's do that
i also have a new charm
minor range charm increase to arrow
damage i'm gonna do the increase to
speeds
uh what did i get techniques i have a
point
um
i'm going to do that i'm going to do
that it's very handy
shield voice um all right you guys i
have a meeting in half an hour
i'm going to eat some lunch before i
have that meeting and then i'm going to
be streaming with inside gaming
[Music]
from uh
i think we're going 4 30 to six
yeah we are um and then i might come
back and stream more i'll just take it
up from exactly where we stopped here
i'll see how i feel i might not want to
continue being on camera all day
but hopefully i will but yeah i gotta
eat and gotta work
uh thank you for joining me you guys i
hope that this is an enjoyable
look at the game comes out it's
technically out in some regions right
now but otherwise comes out tomorrow for
anyone who doesn't know and yeah i've
been playing on playstation pro this
whole time so
i might see you guys a little bit later
thanks for joining
[Music]
bye
you